hello everyone i'm dr umar malik and
welcome to med simplified
edible seeds are currently the
superstars of healthy eating world
mainly due to their amazing health
benefits and unique flavors from flax
seeds to chia and from sunflower to
pumpkin seeds they have clearly
dominated the fitness food scenario
today
we have made several videos on many of
these seeds and their amazing health
benefits and in this video we will
discuss about quinoa seeds so without
further ado let's begin
chinopodium quinoa or simply quinoa is a
flowering plant and it is related to the
amaranth plant and the spinach family
scientists refer to it as a pseudo
cereal this is because the plant appears
like a cereal plant but in reality it
isn't
originally it was grown five thousand to
seven thousand years ago to feed cattle
and livestock
the plant itself traces its origin from
south america growing in the peru and
bolivian regions
in fact the native residents of the inca
believed that it is a sacred plant and
it ensured their animals health
the quinoa plant is about five to seven
feet tall broad and has powdery hairy
leaves the fruit of the seed is about
two millimeter in diameter and may have
varying colors depending upon the
subspecies and the area in which they
are grown
usually they are red to white in the
modern times the quinoa plant has almost
vanished from the original regions of
central america and its production has
spread to other countries like kenya
india usa and some nations in the
european union
in the recent years its popularity has
soared due to the increase in health
conscious mindset of people around the
globe
those who search for easily cultivable
nutrient dense and healthy vegan food
often turn to quinoa seeds due to its
numerous health properties so in this
video let's take closer look at some of
the health benefits of quinoa plant and
why you should include it in your diet
make sure to watch the video till the
very end because in the end we will
discuss about some points as to how you
can include the quinoa seeds in your
diet
number one quinoa seeds are nutrient
rich and gluten free
while it may not seem important to most
people around the globe gluten
sensitivity and gluten related gut
problems are increasingly being
identified in many people
gluten intolerance is the body's
inability to digest or break down gluten
protein found in wheat barley rye etc
in fact some doctors estimate that
around five percent of the us population
is gluten sensitive
although the severity is mild in most of
them
however some may have full blown celiac
disease for such people with gluten
intolerance quinoa seeds being gluten
free can be safely added to the diet
now talking about the nutrient content
let me tell you about some numbers
according to the us department of
agriculture 100 gram or 3.5 ounce of
cooked quinoa seeds has the following
nutrients
70 grams of water 120 kilocalories of
energy 4.5 grams of protein 2 grams of
fat around 3 grams of fiber
it also contains minerals such as 17
milligrams of calcium 65 milligrams of
magnesium 150 milligrams of phosphorus
and 170 milligrams of potassium
and essential minerals such as zinc
copper manganese and selenium are also
present in trace amounts
it also has vitamins such as thymine
riboflavin niacin pyridoxine and folate
it contains no cholesterol and it is
rich in various essential amino acids
people with gluten intolerance often
have to depend on processed foods which
are gluten free
but this processing is expensive
laborious and also deprives the food of
essential nutrients
quinoa seeds provide a gluten-free
source of food without compromising on
fiber folate zinc and magnesium
many researchers consider quinoa seeds
the complete protein source
that is it has all essential amino acids
required by the human body
essential amino acids are the ones that
the body cannot produce on its own
according to the national institute of
health there are nine essential amino
acids histidine isoleucine leucine
lysine methionine phenylalanine
threonine tryptophan and valine
one of the only plant foods known as the
complete protein quinoa seeds offer all
essential amino acids in a healthy
balance
i cannot stress enough on the importance
of amino acids in our body from the
proteins that make our body to the dna
itself is dependent on amino acids
also 100 grams serving provides roughly
5 gram which is surplus to your normal
diet and effectively boosts your body's
nitrogen balance and gives you a
healthier life
number two
fiber fiber and more fiber
if you have been following our videos
about seeds and their health benefits
you might have noticed a trend
seeds are rich in fiber and i always
stress on why fiber is important for us
well a journal published in 2017 titled
closing america's fiber intake gap tells
us that around 90 percent of us citizens
do not have adequate fiber intake
the problem is when asked most of the
people think that they have adequate
fiber intake but most of them are
lacking when it comes to the daily
recommendation
why is fiber important well in short
adequate intake of dietary fiber is
associated with digestive health and
reduced risk of heart diseases stroke
and hypertension
fiber intake also reduces obesity type 2
diabetes and even prevents colon cancers
quinoa is high in fiber plus it has
several vitamins and minerals that are
low in many people's diet
in fact 100 gram serving of quinoa seeds
contains about 3 grams of fiber this is
more than equivalent intake of several
popular food grains such as rice
number three quinoa is antioxidant rich
if we look beyond the nutrient content
of quinoa seeds it offers another range
of health benefits
quinoa is rich in several plant
compounds known as flavonoids
are potent antioxidants
now you may ask why are antioxidants
important well this question deserves a
video of its own but in short when you
have oxidative damage in your body it
means you have too many free radicals in
your body which start to attack your own
cells now this can lead to continuous
low grade inflammation and eventually
certain diseases such as vascular
diseases cancer heart disease and
alzheimer's disease
this is where antioxidants come in
they prevent free radical damage in the
body reduce inflammation and accelerate
the healing process to repair the wear
and tear of the body now that you know
this the two flavonoids found in the
quinoa seeds are quercetin and camphoral
both of these are anti-inflammatory and
antioxidant they promote overall health
and prevent diseases
quinoa also provides vitamin e also
known as tocopherol vitamin e is known
to help in prevention and reduction of
heart disease eye disorders and even
certain cancers
number four quinoa is good for your
heart and cholesterol levels
while there have been various theories
to find out why and if quinoa seeds help
your heart a recent 2020 study attempted
to find conclusive evidence
40 adults were given 15 gram quinoa seed
biscuits daily for 4 weeks
and 40 others were given wheat flour
biscuits over the same time period
after relevant blood investigations for
cholesterol levels and blood sugar
levels the results were charted
the researchers concluded that those who
consumed quinoa biscuits rather than the
wheat ones experienced positive changes
in their blood
this included lowering of bad
cholesterol levels and also total
cholesterol levels
participants lost body weight indicating
the role of quinoa seeds in reducing
obesity
this confirmed the findings of an
earlier trial dull in 2017 which has
said that 50 grams of quinoa seeds daily
leads to moderate yet significant weight
loss in obese individuals
lowering ldl cholesterol and weight is
good for your heart but quinoa seeds can
benefit your body in other ways as well
quinoa seeds are rich in heart friendly
monounsaturated fatty acids such as
oleic acid alpha linoleic acid and
omega-3 fatty acids
these promote lowering of triglyceride
levels and free fatty acid levels
so now that you know about some health
benefits of quinoa seeds let me tell you
about how you can use quinoa seeds
effectively
before you start consuming raw seeds you
should know some things quinoa contains
anti-nutrient compounds such as saponins
tannins and phytates saponins are bitter
and act as a natural insect repellent
also these can interfere with the body's
natural process of nutrient absorption
by binding to iron magnesium and calcium
to prevent this we have a simple
solution
just follow these steps
take a cup of quinoa seeds rinse the
seeds in a strainer
add the seeds and 2 cups of water to a
pot
add some salt for taste
boil this for 15 to 20 minutes
you will know it when the seeds look
fluffy due to water rinse the water and
enjoy the seeds
if done properly the seeds will be nutty
and crunchy to avoid this you can buy
off the shelf quinoa seeds before paying
up just confirm they are rinsed or
sprouted
quinoa seeds taste good and goes well
with various dishes you can enjoy quinoa
seeds any time of the day you can enjoy
the benefits by doing the following
add them to salads and fresh fruits add
them to your trail mix and snacks add
them to grilled veggies or chicken
add them to yogurt or porridge add them
to smoothies or even ice creams
or you can just eat them on your own
you can cook it in bulk and store it in
the fridge for easy meal preparation
so friends if you are looking for a
nutrient rich gluten free alternative
quinoa seeds are your best bet
i have told you the various benefits and
how to enjoy it hope you include it in
your diet as soon as possible
as always if you like this video share
this with your friends and family if you
are new to our channel consider
subscribing if you like our content we
at midsimplified always appreciate your
support and feedback consider becoming a
member of our youtube channel or patreon
community you can find us on instagram
search for med simplified we post daily
facts medical tidbits and posts that
will brighten your day the links are in
the description below take care be safe
and i'll see you in the next video